oh my Gomez the weekend moves in for  kiss and check otis move arm wrapped  around salinas neck and the PDA on full  display can't keep my hands to myself  but this isn't just paparazzi approved  it's Instagram official yet Selena post  then deletes this shot of Abel on the  romantic boat ride in Italy hogging a  staring off into the Stars there's no  doubt the two are collaborating on more  than just new music of course haters  online continue to suggest that Selena's  just using the weekend for a new single  like she reportedly did with dead in  Charlie puth so be hooked up getting  talk anyway but the couple really could  be the real deal after all  Abel supposedly wrote this sexy lyric  about her in the song Hardy Monster High  kalenna  shades I mean so come on guys you never  know they could be a match made in music  heaven